so when your first really big thing was
the hangover and it's like it's turning
15 next year which is crazy incredible
I have to ask because I heard that you
it was your idea to jump out of the
trunk naked yeah is that true it was I
told Todd Phillis the director it would
be because I did have slacks on in the
script and I just said wouldn't it would
it just be so shocking because you had
Mike Tyson he had the tiger that had
already happened in the movie so I asked
Todd I said would what do you think
about Mr Chow jumping out naked he's
like you don't have to tell me twice and
so literally he made me sign a a nudity
writer that I couldn't change my mind to
do it back out yeah I couldn't back out
it was amazing though I just love that
that's a bold move it was really just
honestly if it wasn't for the hangar I
wouldn't I wouldn't be here between
either one of you right now I owe my
career to The Hangover honestly that
well you owe your career to your talent
but yes The Hangover is where we saw you
but your talented why but um are you
like one of those people are you okay
with I love being naked I'm okay with
being naked like a lot of people aren't
like their kids especially where I'm
from in the South they're very
conservative I am not from there
internally like yeah I'm I'm a total
hippie I'm the I'm a I'm so shy like in
Life or I don't I don't even like to
take my shirt off to go to the beach I
wear like those tight skinned like swim
shirts when I go yeah so for me I think
just when the camera's on I'm just
locked in into is it because you're
going to character I think I go into
character mode so right right now I'm
like Hi how are you doing and then
action stupid I
yeah okay you just made me feel weird in
real life
I'm not saying you're weird
I am I just thought most people aren't I
figured you had to be comfortable if you
do it on film but nope
um insane I don't want to be naked or in
the trunk of a car either you would
never do that in a movie uh no I I'm
Shameless yeah yeah it's maybe it's
something about comedy too you know just
taking taking bold choices big swings
that kind of yeah you know I'm joking
I would have wanted to do that that was
[Music]
[Applause]